Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new Mandalorian season 3 video for luke
skywalker grogu their storyline and how mando is
kind of on a similar parallel story arc as grogu
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's a special
bonus episode of mandalorian that's going to
be dropping on friday i'll do a video for that
as well but the really cool thing about grogu's
character is because he is essentially part of
mando's clan you're a clan of two now that makes
him the first mandalorian jedi or he'll become the
first mandalorian jedi in the last thousand years
since the original jedi mandalorian tarer vizsla
that was the mandalorian over a thousand years ago
that trained the jedi temple became a jedi knight
created the darksaber then came back
to his people to become their leader
naming himself the first mandalore so you can see
some of the similarities in what's happening with
mando's storyline and grogu's storyline obviously
grogu is becoming more of a literal jedi mando
just has the darksaber right now and seems like
he is effectively the new mandalore but i know
there are a lot of questions about what's going
to happen with grogu's character in the series
now that they've kind of changed the formula
because grogu left mando and grogu still a main
character on the show he's not leaving the show
and what are they going to do with luke skywalker
during season 3 and future seasons because
now that they've introduced him he's a huge
character they'll have to continue referencing
his character when we keep going back to grogu
especially at the beginning of season 3 before
grogu eventually rejoins mando in future seasons
they're just going to be spending a little bit of
time apart but remember he's not leaving the show
so what happens right now after this moment is
luke skywalker takes grogu in r2-d2 to a hidden
world somewhere controlled by the new republic in
secret there he begins his jedi training there are
a number of different planets that he could take
grogu to that are strong in the force and have
former jedi temples or ruins of jedi temples
within the canon the planet that he trained leia
on was called asian cloths i don't know if they
still want to use that on the mandalorian series
they're just a number of worlds from the legends
canon that they could totally pluck out and bring
forward and just say grogu has been here this
whole time when we pick up with them in season 3
i'm not expecting them to go back to dagobah or
any of the really big planets but that's always
possible too and he'll just continue to train
grogu during that time jump in secret just to keep
him safe because a lot of the galaxy now knows who
luke skywalker is because of the legends that are
spun about him in the destruction of the first
death star then eventually the second death star
and the emperor but the way they explained
it on the mandalorian series is that not
everybody everywhere knows everything about what
happened and how the empire was really defeated
like they don't know that luke skywalker was darth
vader's son they don't know that leia is darth
vader's daughter the reason they have a small
time jump between season 2 and season 3 though
is just because of the way they're plotting out
the story with the book of boba fett taking place
right after the mandalorian season 2 and then the
events of the mandalorian season 3 pick up right
after the events of the boba fett series in the
way pedro pascal talks about it he said that he
expected for his character din jaren to cross over
to all the other mandalorian spin-off series and
it sounds like that includes the boba fett series
they didn't say exactly how many episodes boba
fett is going to be but the way it was talked
about earlier is that it would be a little bit
smaller than the mandalorian series so it might
not be a full eight episodes it might be four
to six episodes but don't be surprised if some of
the mandalorian characters cameo during boba fett
grogu will probably be the exception to that
i don't expect grogu or luke skywalker to show
up during the boba fett series there were a lot
of memes about luke skywalker running into boba
fett 2 on his way to moff gideon's ship like they
pass each other with that car meme as boba fett
is leaving moff gideon's ship and luke skywalker
is arriving like oh wait a minute you're that guy
from jabba's sail barge didn't we kill you didn't
you fall into the sarlacc but within the universe
the time jump will probably be at least a half
year maybe even a full year between the end of
season 2 right here this moment and when they pick
up in season 3 episode one with the characters
but when i say they're changing the formula of the
show that's what they're doing having grogu go off
with luke skywalker but still be a character on
the show so they still have to go back to his
character reference him during episodes somehow
we probably just won't see quite as much of grogu
as we did during season 2 just because he was
always going around with mando they even said that
line of dialogue he goes where i go up to this
point basically the mandalorian series episode
to episode has been a series of fetch quests
like he has a mission in an episode but then
he gets sidetracked for an episode so it's really
like every other episode pushed the story forward
like he tries to take grogu to ahsoka tano but he
gets sidetracked because his ship breaks down and
he can't make it all the way to her planet until
the next episode after that now they're kind of
changing that formula a little bit so they might
change a little bit about the structure of the
episodes but because grogo is with luke skywalker
jedi training right now and luke skywalker is
such a special character and they had to put so
much time and energy and money into that special
deep fake situation it'll probably wind up
being grogu that we see less of than mando
during season 3 the reason why they're on the
similar story arcs though is because they both
answered that higher calling the hero's calling
that they had refused before like grogu was hiding
his jedi abilities inisocatano had this big speech
about how he was afraid that could potentially
lead him on a similar arc as anakin skywalker
i've seen what fear can do to even fully train
jedi that was her big anakin skywalker darth
vader reference now grogu has chosen the jedi
path in gone with luke skywalker and now mando
has chosen to help bo katan answering that higher
calling and now he's wielding the darksaber grogu
is also now kind of the future of the jedi order
and i know there's been all those questions
about what's going on with him in the future
will kylo ren wind up killing him i've already
addressed that in some of my other videos there's
no way that they're going to have kylo ren just
summarily kill off grogu after setting him up and
doing all this with him in the story eventually
some other writer dave filoni or john favreau
will just create a reason for grogu to not be
here when this is happening dave filoni had to
do the exact same thing for grand admiral thrawn
when he recanonized him for star wars rebels where
was thrawn during the clone wars in the original
trilogy if he was such a badass they're actually
going to be explaining that during the ahsoka tano
series with that debuts dave filoni is currently
writing all the ahsoka tano episodes right now and
because of what dave filoni has explained about
the character so far we know that thrawn was in
the unknown regions when a lot of this stuff was
all happening during the original trilogy but when
we pick up with grogu and luke skywalker at the
beginning of season 3 grogu will have already
been training with him for a while because of
that small time jump and will be much stronger
in the force talent without training is nothing
so in the same way that luke skywalker became
more powerful between the events of empire
strikes back and return of the jedi so too will
grogu i think it's a pretty fair comparison in
terms of how much more powerful luke skywalker
was at the beginning of return of the jedi
he didn't start out that movie as a full jedi
knight that didn't really come until his final
test as yoda explained he didn't need any more
training necessarily but he did have to take that
final exam in the dark side choosing to confront
the truth about his father anakin skywalker and
standing against emperor palpatine without falling
to the same fate as anakin skywalker and becoming
the emperor's new apprentice and because jon
favreau is such a fan of referencing the original
trilogy grogu will probably have some easter
eggs and similar story arcs as luke skywalker
when you talk about the way they sort of engineer
the show dave filoni kind of seems like the one
inside their group that are running things who's
all about the deeper mythology the cool obscure
characters and details like bringing the animated
characters into live action or re-canonizing cool
characters from legends like grand admiral thrawn
and john favreau kind of seems like the original
trilogy guy who's all about bringing the major
stuff forward to this part of the timeline i
posted a video the other day where he went on
about how much he loved return of the jedi as
a kid and wondered what happened to all the
characters after that and now he's actually
getting to tell that story but the way that jon
favreau the other people are talking about this
big luke skywalker reveal his big cameo scene
is that it sounds like they won't spend a ton of
time with the deep fake version of luke skywalker
on screen but he'll continue to be an important
character to the mandalorian cinematic universe in
this part of the timeline training grogu and any
other jedi that come along and ultimately helping
them with grand admiral thrawn there have been
a lot of recent rumors i saw after the finale
about lucasfilm wanting to do a luke skywalker
jedi academy series on disney plus i don't know
if that's true but i think for at least the next
couple seasons of the mandalorian series we'll
probably only actually see him cameo maybe once
or twice more maybe even a little bit less than
that and mostly what'll happen is the other main
characters like dinjara and ahsoka tano eventually
any of the other characters from the new republic
will just reference luke skywalker but just
in terms of this really cool parallel between
the story arcs that grogu and din jarner on so
obviously when we pick up with season 3 grogu
will still be jedi training with luke skywalker
mando will also probably be training with the
darksaber because even though he's already a
really badass fighter he's never used the dark
saber before and you have to use very special
fighting techniques when using a lightsaber like
that so through circumstance mando sort of finds
himself on a similar story arc as the original
mandalore the original mandalorian jedi knight
even though it seems like grogo himself will
technically be the first mandalorian jedi in over
a thousand years they keep referencing mandalore
the great who is tarvisla the original mandalorian
jedi the person who created the darksaber so they
keep referencing that through mando's storyline
so he's sort of on a similar arc as that character
so luke skywalker will continue to be a really
important character to the mandalorian series
and the spin-off series like ahsoka tano
hopefully he gets a cameo on that as well
but we're not going to see him in every single
episode again if there's any other news that i
think is legit about that luke skywalker disney
plus series i will do videos about it if you have
any big questions about what's going on with the
characters or bonus videos you want to request
just let me know in the comments i will do a video
for that bonus episode of the mandalorian this
weekend there's also a bunch of content that's
going to be dropping in and around the christmas
holidays so make sure you have alerts turned on
from my channel so you don't miss any of those
everyone click here for my new mandalorian season
3 episode and click here for my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 8 finale video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!